[Music]
hmm
hi sylvio uh hi
i'm so excited that you're here and that
um
you know you've come to visit us in the
simons institute back to berkeley
after being a graduate student here for
so many years you know especially i'm
i'm honored to interview you having a
pleasure
such a great collaborator and even
better friends for so many years
so um so sophia tell me
how do you feel being back at berkeley
first of all i think very good i've
always a soft spot for uh for berkeley
and
of course and uh in some sense uh
people say that you know yet to be
they are way for a long long time to be
able to realize that everything is back
as it was
and so right now perhaps has been such a
long time
and i really feel back at home and as i
left
that's wonderful so you came to berkeley
in 1978
79 because my english was so bad that i
was admitted
from the fall of 79 but uh finally
the score of a total the test of english
is a foreign language
we're so poor to say well you are
admitted but you have to improve the
english so six months later
somehow i made it enough you know
but also says okay we have to meet you
so i arrived there was a trimester
back then and i arrived i don't know at
the third trimester you know
and then obviously last trimester of 79.
then
we started innate it together that's
right that's right
so uh you came in and you came from
rome from the university of rome yes
correct and what made you go into
computer science and
uh theoretical computer science and
berkeley
oh okay so first of all i started in
physics
for whatever reason and but at that time
you know
we started six months a semester was
dedicated to mathematics
and so i followed the calculus and
geometry before doing any physics and at
that time
i decided muff is whatever i wanted to
do and then
the professor of math or culture of
actually mathematical analysis at the
time
he was saying you know don't do math you
know so for a young person
don't do analysis at all just to do
physics and much better columns there
and say well i don't want to do physics
i want to do mathematics
then he said well there is at least you
know one branch of mathematics and he
told me about um
gerald's work or the touring's work and
he says if you really want
yet to do that however he warned me you
need to have a big stomach
for those things and so i
heard about a big stomach you know
because it's not
for the light-hearted according to him
right so he realized that they were um
so he was afraid of indigestion i was
afraid of indigestion
and uh i of course you know i gave him
the right advice but i didn't follow it
i
i continued for a while in mathematical
analysis and then
finally i took you know the last year of
um
before graduation i took some a logic
course and some london calculus course
from
cogado bem and i decided you know what
maybe discrete mathematics is actually a
good idea
and i decided to uh to make
my thesis in lambda calculus and so then
i went to a graduate uh you know
as a seminar summer seminar in um in uh
in algorithms and i
suddenly learned about algorithm so now
i'm projecting from the continuous now
to a very discreet
finally two algorithms and then at the
end i decided you know
i want to do theoretical computer
science and what a better place to do it
within berkeley and so being uh
ignorant of the ways of the world i only
applied to berkeley luckily enough i got
in and
uh and and now here i am a graduate
student
exactly and at that time in berkeley
there are all these uh
theorists which because we were graduate
students together i remember that i
thought that they were ancient
but i think they were much younger than
we are today right there
absolutely there's the carp manuel blum
gene lawler and they seem like they've
been
around forever right yes and the hour
just
uh arrived or just uh
maybe a year before or just around the
same in 1980 and uh
yeah i was really the place to be in
theoretical computer science respect
i thought he arrived in 82 82 yeah yeah
i thought so
yes it was a place to be and uh do you
remember anything about those days about
your cohorts or graduate students or the
kind of classes you took
or the atmosphere the atmosphere was
always a
very collaborative right and someone
somehow
my graduate students you being one you
know it was a kind of a
band of brothers right who decided to
unleash ourselves on the town as well as
uh
on mathematical problems and um
i i mean i i really remember to take
a course in algorithm from dick and uh
the carp
and uh to collaborate with jay
and uh vijay was able was better
organized than i was
to follow to do research and follow the
course i was terrible so i essentially
dropped the course
but at the end of the day we finally had
an algorithm for general matching which
uh
we are very proud of and i continue to
be proud of that the result and then
later on there was emmanuel blam with
his course on on
computational number theory with
application to cryptography
and then i believe uh you and i together
decided that uh cryptography was so
exciting and nobody knew
anything about it it was not an academic
discipline the last three lectures were
about cryptography
and what a better promise to work on
when something is totally undefined
ill-defined and or unclear what it is
and and that's what um we started doing
and there was
no looking back at that point so i i
really remember
that you know the teachers were great at
berkeley but i think
we learned from each other at least as
much as we learned from our
great teachers and the vet was
really a lesson for life i really
believe that interaction
really is the way to go if you want
particular if you want to tame
a new field because you need to have you
know immediate feedback
and uh and sometimes there is a
a lot of depression and be able to to
solve the problems right away
and uh so if you are together somehow at
least one or
can be in a good enough mood to
re-emerge and continue
that's true so you've actually described
that in a very short period of three
four years i don't know if you realize
this
you went from working on lambda calculus
and logic to working on graph algorithms
and you
what you did in graph algorithms was a
result that stood for many many years i
don't
actually know if there is actually
already a better algorithm from general
graphs note
that's right and yours was for general
graphs right so you went from logic
and lambda calculus to graph algorithms
and then to cryptography now
cryptography i know the story but i'd
like our
viewers to know the story um
you know today we have programs at
simon's about pseudorandomness you know
the whole program is being dedicated to
it
but at the time that field did not exist
so do you remember sort of
the beginning of uh sort of your thesis
your work on
randomness randomness versus hardness
well um yes so
i i do remember first of all i remember
beta manuela mentioned all this
promo momentum poker that somehow you
and i
decided to attack in retrospect was a
very hard problem but we were able to
distill out a very meaningful piece
which was you know
encryption and and so we started working
on encryption probabilistic encryption
because when you deal with encrypting
just a few cards there is only 52 of
them so
you need to have the encryption to be
probabilistic and define what it means
to add the partial information and so on
so forth but for um
for um and then later on we start doing
a multi-party protocol
later for um
for um pseudo-randomness i really
remember one thing but once i got to
this little books
about science and i was not a scientist
when i grew up i was
doing a high school in was a classical
eye school
i was doing a literature philosophy
history
greek ladies and whatever but very
little mathematics
except for euclidean geometry and it was
enough by the way to hook me
onto math but but remember i
i had this popularization of various
things there was a this
book about tides in which they said then
even though the equations of tides are
very very well known as a part of really
newtonian mechanics totally understood
somehow
the calculations the steps were so
intricate that somehow it was
randomness emerged from this thing and i
so they explicitly discussed that in
this book
like just yeah as i've thought in order
to say
well why do we study these things that
they are so predictable the moon we know
we should
we should know exactly what happened and
they complained that you don't
quite know and you start seeing you know
something
and so somehow i got to this idea that
maybe you know it is
uh something to do the computation is so
long what the hell i knew
right so but it's about that thought
stuck in my mind and you know i really
believe that the thoughts are stuck in
our mind and when that with
education scientific education you just
be able to elaborate
with initial thoughts but it's the
initial thoughts that
hook us okay so finally
uh so we were exposed
not in uh in precise form to the notion
of
a one-way function right and
so that's it i got convinced that this
one-way function so easy in one
direction and right in one
in the other direction was the key to
pseudorandomness
because you want to generate fast with
the bits the random bits but you want
them to be
unpredictable and that was actually the
subject of my phd this is
how to generate a pseudo random beats
you know
based on my cryptographic function even
the title was uh
very complex so yeah i
really uh that was very a bit somehow
um things were random because
you didn't have enough time to predict
exactly
and uh not so only so but you can
amplify
this uh a little bit uncertainty to
really make it a
zero one with essentially probability 50
50
ability of predicting at least in any
finite time yes
and so so in general
cryptography at the time was about
communication
pseudorandom generation was not a part
of uh
communication it was a different breed
and uh
so somehow the notion that instead that
you could use the same tool
for cryptography for doing pseudorandom
generation
was was new and at this point you know
the way we understand you know
complexity basic cryptography
essentially has become
a science of computation in the presence
of an adversary
and the adversary can try to figure out
what the message we're exchanging that
diversity can try to figure out what
the next bit that we generate in a
pseudorandom generator are
the diversity is going to try to
convince you of a false statement in a
proof where diversity is everywhere
and um it's interesting that you
mentioned the adversary
so um there's several threads here
one is this uh existence of the
adversary which is
a common to all of these seemingly
different challenges like
private communication or generation
which is unpredictable
then another thread that you've
mentioned is the idea that hardness is
something that
it seems hard to compute has is very
strongly linked to
unpredictability which today i think we
take as a given in this field
but it is really quite quite a deep
insight
um i uh it's it's
and i think it's uh it's beautiful the
way that these two things uh connect
together
i want to pick up on something else that
you mentioned you talked about
multi-party computation so multi-party
computation is development that
happened a little bit later when i think
you moved to mit
right you had some work where uh there
was
several people they're collaborating
each one has an input and somehow they'd
like to collaborate
collectively compute a common output
without revealing to each other the
input
more than is implied by the function
value
so it took many many years but today
that seems to be something that
is actually known widely to scientific
community i don't know if you know that
in the congress they've discussed this
there are some
special uh interest groups who are
discussing multi-party
computation multi-party collaborations
as a way to do
things we cannot do otherwise um
sure i mean that makes sense right so um
so the law very often tries to uh
to convince us to do the honest thing by
punishing whenever we deviate
but the best thing is to make a
deviation impossible or
for instance there is all kinds of
situations in which you know you want to
you want to punish inside trading
but if you do the right
type of multi-party computation if you
can say hey i couldn't do inside
training because
i i didn't know what was going on how
can i do inside training if everything
is encrypted and we compute them with uh
on this encryption and keep the data so
yes the possibilities
is uh is there so to me
uh i i'm always an impatient man
so it was very frustrating to see that
some of his research which was uh
clearly going to affect the way we
conduct our life
we've been conducting on uh business
interactions
in a secure way in an open way and yet
uh
in a private way correct and privacy
together
and you know it took a long time to with
to this ideas to trickle into
into products that we can actually use
uh
routinely and to me we are still not
quite there yet in the
widespread adoption of these things so
it was a good lesson to see that you
know it takes time
it is good to it takes time for basic
research
to um to become you know
available to society and that's by the
way why is important to continue funding
you know basic research because
it takes a long time but it will give
you know great
foods and revolutionize the way we
interact with each other
absolutely in another place apparently
that multiparty computation the same
kind of multi-party computation that we
were talking about in the 80s and
at berkeley in the beginning then at mit
is being used now in machine learning
why because when they're doing uh
training of models they need to take a
lot of data from a lot of different
sources
and they want people don't necessarily
want to contribute their data
organizations don't necessarily want to
view their data so they have something
called federated learning where you have
essentially multi-party computation
among the contributors of data that they
go through a protocol where they
contribute their data to learn machine
models
and this is like bread and butter do i
contribute sorry to have a larger sector
so you want to come up with a model with
a machine learning algorithm but that
model is data driven okay
it's not that you know how this program
is going to run the data is going to
some i'll teach you how to develop the
model like
an oral network so uh who where is this
data coming from these are data
individuals and the example that people
usually use is that
on your on your iphone you type and they
want to come up with predictive
correction of text but there's many
users and these users don't necessarily
want everybody to know what they're
typing
so you want to do a multi-party
computation among many users
where you don't know what a single user
is doing but altogether this is going to
serve as data for
training machine learning algorithms so
that's again another example for impact
from cryptographic protocol from the 80s
to something that's being done today and
has been hailed as one of the biggest
impacts on industry
so coming back to you since we're
interviewing you yep yep yep
we're only in the 80s we're only around
86 87
and after that you went and did a whole
bunch of work on distributed computing
on
uh byzantine agreement and consensus do
you want to tell us a little bit about
that
yeah so so somehow
i really believe you know
byzantine agreement is a quintessential
way you know
to keep a consistent view of the world
in the presence you know
in a fault tolerant way right and the
best way
to model uh false is to have an
adversary
again now we go back to the adversary
because given any system
if it is complex enough and you wait
long enough it behaves as if it is a
really malicious adversary
so you might as well model that way so
it makes sense
that the
reaching agreement in presence of of
adversary and the problem
was uh defined by peace shows like in
lamport um
in the 80s and uh but somehow the
protocols
were very very very slow and uh because
of um
you had to um to have as many
steps in the protocol as
potentially bad players plus one so if
the number of players is large
then uh you have to wait for a long time
to reach a byzantine agreement right
and so somehow i thought i would say hey
you know i know something about
the diversity but they're not competing
in one adversary i want to try my hand
at the problem
and actually my first phd i granted was
on
to a phd to a student to a student
this is paul feldman yes
he graduated in 85 and uh
and with uh a thesis on um on
um um on byzantine agreement and i
really felt a vitamin really respected
the distributor computation
and uh and uh having solved the vet
problem
i felt as a check you know now we solve
other problems
and strange enough and then re-emerging
my more recent uh
research so in fact this was the next
thing that i want to ask you about
although we're skipping a whole period
where you worked about by on biology
on finding a cure for aids for some
point you are interested in it's
theology
different funding and then you worked on
algorithmic game theory and auctions uh
but let's kind of uh
fast forward and uh what are you
interested in today what are you working
on today
i know that it has to do with presenting
agreements and cryptography
but i'd like to hear it from you well
you know i
i'm working on distributed ledgers right
and and and somehow blockchains uh
and so somehow they the idea
with the blockchains they are now over
2000 proposals right or now
how to do these things and but um they
are mostly a variant of of
each other so what you want there you
want to have you know
a set of data like organized in blocks
one block after another and so you
so that you cannot alter the content of
the blocks
and you cannot alter the order of a
block so that's it
and the chain and but you know i guess
what if this is not a static data you
want to keep on
adding blocks so all these 2000 things
they use
the same technologies very primitive
cryptographies of
50 years ago there's 2000 uh blockchains
yeah so
the chain is actually the same in every
project that they do some hashing the
usher one block is part of the other
block and that prevents you from
altering the content without this
alteration to be visible and percolates
everywhere but guess what but the real
problem is
how do you who is in charge of
generating the new block
and that's where the old poem is right
and uh
and so people have found you know mr or
mrs nakamoto
um from bitcoin on bitcoin and they
figure out a way which is
to create a very uh big puzzle
which is very hard to solve and the
first one to solve it in some sense as
the right to do a block so this way you
say who has the right hey
work very very hard on this problem the
first one to win
or solve it otherwise
to generate a new block that's one way
it creates a lot of
uh is it kind of slow because you have
to wait
for this problem to be to be solved is
very expensive
and uh strange enough for reasons that
aren't something to do with uh
with incentives that somehow generates
you know concentration of power in uh
what you want is that the distributed
ledger is that somehow nobody's in
charge right obviously
all ever going database and uh
and that defeats the purpose and other
ways
are going to say okay we don't want to
spend so much energy here is what we do
we put you know
a few people in charge a few because you
can manage to get more efficient that
way
and we are in charge of choosing the
next block
well is vested decentralized uh no and
they have all kinds of other variations
um
also called the proof of stake um
which you know somehow is
they look good but they're not in my
opinion as good as they
they should be to guarantee really at
the centralization of the system
and so all of a sudden i i thought about
and said
so maybe how about we agree on the block
but to have really the entire community
agree on the block so
i dusted off all this notion of a
byzantine agreement and tried to
and try to figure out if we can make it
so efficient
and uh so compelling so that you know to
allow even a billion
people to agree on a block very quickly
and uh and without having the
computation without having the
centralization in any shape or form
and the source of velvet was uh what
i've been
working on and and that is only one
piece
if it doesn't you know the other pieces
that you know
something to do with designing a system
of incentives uh
and so on and so forth um to keep the
know of the system operating properly
and i understand also part of uh having
this large large-scale byzantine
agreement
is uh how to select uh a subcommittee
that will actually agree and the
selection of the subcommittee again
has uh sort of a random selection or a
pseudo-random selection
so we go back to your pseudorandom days
that actually weighs in on
current interest yes so in some sense
you know
um so okay so
having a billion people agree on
something it says here is one idea the
billion people agree on a thousand
people and then a thousand people agree
on a block
so wow that should be working because
from a billion to a thousand you have uh
you know an order of uh six order of
magnitudes
uh efficiency but can you imagine a
billion people can agree on anything
never not on a committee or then against
on the block they might as well agree on
the block
directly right so um so the question is
veteran how do you
somehow how somehow do you select
with a committee and strange enough of a
very at least there is a
utilizing here is to have these people
to select themselves but in a way that
forces themselves not to cheat
so that even though you are in charge of
selecting your yourself
think about it that you have you know an
individual lottery
that is only uh personalized to you
and you try to it takes a micro second
to see if you wouldn't use the lawyer or
not
you cannot alter the result in the same
microsecond so to speak you know i
and everybody else see if they won't the
people who win
have a proof that they won and they come
out to say here is my winning ticket
i'm part of this committee and here is
my
opinion about the block so to speak
right and so the idea is to have a
really
cryptographic randomness and algorithmic
randomness it comes really to
to the rescue and in particular a
particular brand
of um as you know we mentioned uh
generation observer random beats
together um we did you know
we've ordained uh pseudo-random function
uh
generators from generator to functions
and here we need a special other thing
which is a verifiable random functions
which now came very late in this
progress of
algorithmic randomness whereas all term
so i was uh in good company with
michael rabin uh salil madan and
we are in the 2000 and it is with
variant because in a in a
in a verifiable random function you
actually you can
so you you can actually use it yourself
because you know everybody's guaranteed
but not any input
you are forced even if you choose your
keys in a special way to end up very
actually random output and that's what
makes the real thing convincing so it's
a beautiful
combination you know so there's
pseudorandomness or verifiable
randomness
there is byzantine agreement there is
the notion of a committee that gets
elected and and at the end you know
there's this block that's being posted
on blockchain but we all know that the
interest in some sense in blockchain
is uh um commercial
in the sense that uh the reason why the
public knows about it
is because of this cryptocurrency which
has kind of cut their
imagination uh so i find it interesting
that whereas early on
our inventions it took a long time to
come to fruition in the sense of impact
uh here the impact of uh
of all your work coming together into
blockchains
the theoretical ideas in the impact are
coming at the same time
um it feels uh so first of all i wonder
what your
thoughts about that is how theory and
practice are coming closer together
these days
and two um can you tell us a little bit
about applications of distributed
ledgers and blockchains beyond currency
okay i have to choose available so
let's start with the ladder because i
remember okay if i forget that there are
two questions
coming uh coming at the same time much
more so than in the fut in the past
and the second is applications of
blockchains beyond currency
okay so first of all um
theorem practice uh i don't believe that
uh necessarily
we are now entering an age in a in which
you know theorem practice are now
close together and it it occurs in the
renaissance in other things which there
were
really times in which you know the
distance of a temporal distance between
theory and practice
was very um very small but i believe of
it you know we are going to have another
example so we are going to go back to
the good old ways in which you know the
fear is developed for
for a while and uh and somehow the
practice uh
lags behind the forgotten of reasons
social
uh cultural uh political and everything
else
so but never never mind wait so um
so what what is an application in my
opinion if
if you look at uh yes
by the way having you know a mean of a
medium of exchange is a great
application of ledgers right and
and to have a cryptocurrency that really
scales and is a medium of exchange would
be great but
by the way they're not there here
tonight because whatever products are
out there
they they lack of a they lack of the
um the full boot uh
and the security algorithm so practice
is not there that is not there yet
but but in my opinion the real
application of these layers
is to leverage a trust that is diffused
across the society and concentrated
into an interaction between you and an
individual so let me give you an
example assume that we live in different
continents right
and assume that um we want so therefore
we don't know each other
so there is very little trust about each
other
and so what do we want to do is that we
want to say
to do a simple operation like a digital
design a contract okay
so we have negotiated a contract now we
know what the contract should look like
as i say is a shafty
now we are far away
digitally signed and sent in your
digital signage and i promise to
digitally control sign
and now we have an executed contract
because both signature has to be there
and what we're going to say is silver
brilliant but let me suggest a better
idea sure so you digitally sign
first and then i promise to digitally
contact sign
later and of course you know because
whoever
signs first is on the hook right and the
other one is not on the hook
and so you know we can communicate with
the speed
of light we can do anything or it's
about whoever takes the first action
that is a strategic thinking has nothing
to do with the speed of light
and so if we there is not enough trust
and nobody wants to go first
so how do we solve these problems okay
we go
to a trusted party uh call it a judge
if you know but um colony goldman sachs
if it is a
financial application assuming that we
are goldman sachs
but you know first of all problem number
one we do not have
we may not have a trusted third party
that
we both with trust what do we do second
even if
we have this trusted party how the
transaction looks like
oh it's easy many transactions look like
say you shall receive
the trusted party a contradiction
assigned by shafty verify air signature
you should also receive a contra digit
designed by silvio verify his signature
then verify that bit by bit by bit the
controller sylvian chaffee
sign is absolutely identical if so swap
give
shafi's if you're seeing each other i
said you know what this is going to take
two days because we have to explain
whatever we need from this roster party
but never mind that
first party wanted to be paid so it's
going to have you know
a company bill of two thousand dollars
to the trusted party to
enable us to transact so it's going to
take two days
and two thousand dollars i'm making you
know numbers out of thin air but you get
the idea
okay assume there is instead a ledger in
which
blocks appears as every few seconds and
everybody sees the content of these
blocks
and everybody knows that whatever i see
everybody else also sees
is a kind of a common knowledge
situation then i'm going to say hey chef
you know
you know what fine i go first but the
way i go first
abstract label is like basically say i
silvio oblige myself with contribution
if and only if
my signatures and sharpies signatures
together appear
in block say one five one assume the
current block
is one five zero a few seconds later i'm
going to look in this
ledger that is the same for everybody
that's a beauty
and now case one my senior engineer
signage are there
then we have a valid contract right okay
if my signature is there it's not
yours is not or wherever we're around
i'm free to
sell the house whatever the country is
to somebody else because i know that
everybody
else sees that is only mine and not also
yours were there right
time few seconds cost zero nobody beats
this and i don't need to trust you right
so
we are leveraging a trust spread out and
be able to concentrate in an interaction
appear to peer interaction and i think
that you know that is going to generate
so much uh potential as the potential to
generate
so much a trust that in in in in society
that is going to enable
not only to uh to pay each other
but not but also to to do more
sophisticated transactions like this
and by the way smart contracts which is
still
way above always is a very uh
interesting way to do things and
therefore in some sense if these legers
uh if
uh trust is a quintessential right in
human interaction so if you can
generate the trust out of thin air
because tell your truth i trust
the fact that the majority of societies
is honest about i don't know
a particular individual is honest or not
so i'm going to be very
uncertain i go back to have a
centralized world in which you know a
few people
decides uh make themselves the trusted
parties and they
if you want to transact you to consult
for them now
there is better alternatives we can
organize ourselves you know
in uh in direct ways so potentially
there is a
great application for these things but
again we must
realize this potential and it's only
technology that vienda
is going to make this possible yeah i
agree with you
so actually we're having a semester here
in the fall on distributed ledgers and
and distributed consensus which
hopefully a lot of these ideas are going
to be flush and there will be sort of
future applications maybe more
technology
i just want to touch on one point that
you've mentioned throughout the
interview which we didn't talk about
and that is you talked about paul
feldman who was your first phd student
yep you've had a lot of pc phd students
since they've
gone on to do great things they're in
many universities around the world
um how do you feel about these students
i mean what's your first of all
i feel so i'm extremely proud of my
students
so i think that you know has been really
a gift to
help them but the truth is that they
helped me way more when i helped them
right and uh and that is i believe it is
a
really great gift to be an educator and
to be in academia but
somehow you are in touch with young
people and i
really believe that young people
are always right and so if you there is
no better
way to figure out if a problem is good
or not but to try to
say how about we try to solve this
problem there is a
look wormish things and maybe the bomb
is not important
but if there is any chance that what is
good
i mean the students will get it
immediately
and uh and after that everything is easy
so i really think it is really
a privilege to be an educator and
actually a beneficiary of
being in touch with uh with his uh
future generations and
um so let me give you a compliment
as a final please remark and that is
that i think you are a great
educator not only to your students but
also to your colleagues
and uh i remember this originally and
also for years
that uh you had this gift of explaining
things to me
like you would explain things and then i
would understand them
and it wasn't really explaining a method
but there was something about the way
would articulate what's important what's
not important
that it was really quite quite a gift
and a helpful one well first of all
thank you for your interview thank you
for my compliment
the truth of the matter is it's so hard
for me to understand anything
about the time which i i understand
maybe i'm also
capable of explaining and so they my
secret is to be
it's heart of understanding and so
somehow
perhaps that works or to to advantage of
everybody
whatever works thank you thank you
[Music]
shelfie
[Music]
you
[Music]